Reebok just named two of the biggest NBA
legends ever to run their basketball
Division and they're about to run things
differently Shaquille O'Neal has been
named Reebok's president of basketball
and Alan Iverson is the new VP of
basketball Shaq went from launching his
first shoe brand Shaq attack back in
1992 to now becoming the face of the
operation even after he left to launch
his own Dunkman brand it ended up being
a short separation between him and
Reebok and he came back in 2012 to
launch the Retro series but now he gets
to shape everything in His image and
especially with the new addition of alen
Iverson who will be tasked with player
recruitment it's safe to say that Reebok
is in good hands